all right thank you and welcome welcome
welcome good morning good afternoon good
evening good everything my name is one
and today I have a very let's call it
light and even fun presentation which
I'm calling getting better at Pokemon
using data Python and chat GPT now once
again my name is Juan and I work as as a
software engineer for the trust and
safety te a bit however for today I
would like to remove this title and just
call myself a fan of python data and of
course Pokemon so please follow me now I
feel like I need to start this talk by
saying how much I love the Pokemon
Trading Card Game it's fun it's cool I
the competition and of course it's good
to making friends I just moved here to
this city around years ago and I
realized I noticed there's like a huge
Pokemon TR community so I would mean an
know billions of poke friends however as
much as I like the game I need to admit
that I'm very bad at it as you can see
here that all those are some pictures of
myself playing the game and I do not
look happy at all so in an attempt to
get better uh learn from my mistake I
started to use a resource that we all
here like or we should right and that's
data so I started to collect data on my
games with the goal of analyzing then in
the future uh using a mix of that
include python yay R JavaScript Google
sheet and chat jpt yes a lot of things
but have I got any better I don't really
know please you be the judge however at
least I have a very cool presentation to
share with all of you now this is the
agenda for today after this short
introduction I'm going to present my
first of three projects the first one is
called will I draw a battle baby pass
the second one is I'm going to talk
about a data analysis that I did uh
using information that are from 100
matches and then I'm going to present
how I Evol my
notebook from the second project into a
dashboard in Google sheet and then of
course unfortunately I need to end my
presentation so follow me will I draw a
battle py pass parenthesis all the
picture that you will see here I did it
myself I'm also an Abid photographer and
of course I like to also take pictures
of card so please enjoy them now uh some
basic rules right before we start
a Pokemon deck has 60 cards 60 cards
here you see that 60 at the start of
each game each player draws seven cards
and an additional six cards that are the
prices so once again 60 minus 7even that
you start with and then you have like
another six now you do not know what are
those other six cards B they are your
prices and to get them you get either
one two or three every time Youk an
oppon poon and of course the first
player to take SE prices wins the game
also we need to know that at the start
of each turn you draw a
card and now with this rule in mind I
wanted to know the odds of drawing a
bottle baby pass in my initial hand and
in my initial
draw what's so special about this card
like why do I want it well this card is
very good because it lets you uh to to
look for up to two basic Pokémons on
your deck and then place them onto your
B Ben your bench can have a maximum of
five Pokemon so having two of them and
getting them of one card is a big deal
however this one big catch in this card
and that's that you're only allowed to
play it during your first turn so after
the first turn this card is essentially
dead is useless so you want to increase
the odds of seeing this car during your
first turn and so I started looking
around and reading and trying to find
like how can I calculate this and of
course there are many guys online but I
wanted to do it by myself right so I
could learn about it and then I find uh
I found out something called a hyper
geometric distribution and this one is a
one that tells you the likelihood of
throwing a specific number of items from
a set without putting them back or
without replacement for example suppose
that you have one bucket and you have
red and green balls well this
distribution calculates the chances of
picking up a certain number of green
balls in a handful of draws or in my
case what are the chances of drawing
this elusive carard from a deck of 60
cards and now I want to introduce two
different cases right the first one is
the probability of getting one batttle B
pass in my initial hands and here we
have the hyper geometric distribution we
have some sort of binomial coefficients
like K choose n multi by another one
divided by n choose n and these are
values here we have that n is population
size in this case it's going to be 60
because I have 60 cars in on my deck
right then I have K which is the number
of successes in population in this case
is four because my deck has four passes
the sample size is seven because as I
mentioned before you're are going to
draw seven cards in your first hand and
then K here is the number of successes
in the sample which is one because I
want to at least see one card so I
quickly went here I replaced all the
values and I started to do it by hand
but I realized like oh these numbers are
quite huge so I need to use Python so I
went to python
I and then voila this is the number 33.
63% and yet I never seem to see the card
but now besides knowing the odd of
drawing one I also wanted to know the
same for zero two three or four VIP
passes and instead of doing the whole
thinge I went to python I Google how to
calculate the hyper geometric
distribution and of course CPI has this
function implemented so I wrote a very
tiny function that calculates the
distribution from zero up to four and
here in this small comment like down
there you can see the answer so we have
60% of droing zero IP pass or we have
33% of droing one which is what I show
before almost 6% of
cn2 uh
0.38 % of Scene Three and almost 0% of
scene four and that's something that
have never ever seen before and here we
have in a small visualization the same
data I did this using R and you can see
that huge drop from one to two so if you
actually if you don't see at least one
the chances of getting two are very very
slow actually I have here my deck let's
see I just draw seven cards seeing them
one two three four five 6 s do I have it
let's see and the answer is of course no
I do not have it right here so I keep
telling you I never see that card now
let's suppose that I didn't see any card
in my initial hand and let's also
suppose that I don't have one of them in
my prices so what are the probability of
getting one in my initial draw the
numbers here they are almost the same
except by the population size which is
because I have my 60 minus my initial
seven cars minus the six cars I have in
my prices and here the number of the
sample size is one because I'm just
throwing one
card and the answer is
8.51 so if I didn't see any in my first
one then at least I have almost 10% of
draw in my first draw maybe it's this
one that I have here no it's not so as
you can see well I need a little bit of
L now for the second project
and this one I'm calling it what I have
learned after tracking a 100 matches and
at some point I decided to track the
outcome and details of my Pokemon
matches that I have played using an
archetype of a deck called Lost box fun
fact why is it called This Way well
because this type of deck wants you to
get as many cards into something called
The Lost Zone I know it's a cool name
because good things happen when you get
to four seven and 10 if you want to know
just ask me the very end and this is my
data set pretty straightforward it has
nine eight eight columns and well 97
rows each for one game we can see that
the first one is the time when I did the
match then got the deck all of them here
are going to be lost box of course in
parenthesis you have the variation
because I use around nine of them then I
have the opponent's deck then we have
the outcome which here either win or
lose now that I see it is should have
been either better I one or zero the
prices left that's the number of prices
I had left at the end of the match the
same with my opponent then I have
another column that uh has information
of whether I went first or second here
is zero or one which is what what I
wanted to do before with the outcome and
then have some notes which I'm going to
explain a bit later so I took all this
data I loaded into a Jupiter notebook
and I was like well let's um the data
let's see what I can find and this is
the first of the interesting Insight
that I got from here and here we see the
ratio the win ratio over time or how my
exactly how my win ratio has evolved as
I keep playing games and here we have
several decks and they are colorcoded
that that's the tiny color that you see
there so my first two matches they were
very good I won all of them
congratulations to me and that's why the
win ratio there is one Z or 100% then of
course the third game I lost and the win
ratio dropped to
66% and then of course we can see that
it went up and it has several ups and
down now uh of those decks the one that
I would really enjoy the most the one on
green which is called Dragonite or the
turbo version of the deck and then we
can see that at some point maybe after
80 matches my record started to decrease
a little bit and that's when I stopped
using the deck
this is another visualization and in
this one I have the win ratio for each
of the L de variation well as I
mentioned before the first two decks I
only Ed the once however I won those
games so the win ratio is 1.0 but then
we have another one like the Baseline
version which I play six times let me
increase my notes Here quickly because I
very see the numbers and then we also
have uh the one that the most with it
Dragonite with our around a sample of
63% and a win ratio over
60% now something very similar but this
time is the win ratio against my
opponent's deck and here we can see that
the first one the win ratio is very very
high against some decks called cha Mong
ex or Garda by the way it feels very
funny saying these words here in a
conference because that's you usually
the nerd of
me then we have another one called
random this is essentially like
a right for all the rest of the decks
and then we have other decks like gutina
Lo and mu and Lugia now the last one the
win ratio is uh one
0.4 and yes if you ask anyone who plays
Pokemon and you ask what is the wor
match up for L box they're going to say
Lugia because it's almost I don't want
to say almost impossible but it's very
hard to win against that deck and I also
see it in my data with only 40% of
matches in my favor
for the histograms and here I wanted to
know more information about how many
prices me or my opponent we had left at
the beginning at the end of matches this
one in particular is a histogram of the
prices I had left at the end of matches
that I lost and we can say that the mean
here is 4.5 now you might be asking hey
ju like 4.5 is quite a high mean
considering you only have six prices yes
that's true it means two things that
when I lost I lost by a lot and also and
this is not an excuse is that sometime
if I feel like the match is not going in
my favor or if I feel like my initial
hand is bad for example if I don't have
a ble py pass I'm just going to concede
the game and be like you know what you w
let's go to the next one why because
when you are in an official sanction
tournament you only have 50 minutes to
finish a whole set so if I know I'm
going to lose i' rather just go to the
next game and maybe I'll win that one
the same thing but for my opponent
perspective here the m is 4.1 is a bit
lower than mine but also realize that
many opponents they actually do not
conit as much as I
do now for my notes right so beyond
numbers I also wanted to record
qualitative data in the forms of notes
and these notes they contain information
such a key moments mistakes and learning
from each game for example one of them
says forgot to use manafi which is a
very important card or too slow like me
telling me myself I was playing too slow
or good handle of a mirror match and
that's when the opponent is playing the
same deck as you now given the nature of
these notes I know that analyzing then
is not easy I wanted to do something
more substantial than just counting
keywords phrases and whatnot so uh I
need to admit that my NLP skills are not
that great and it's been quite some time
since the last time I did something
important using NLP so I had no idea
where to start right so I just copy pay
this I went to sh GPT and I told GP and
that's how I call it GP please could you
summarize all this information right and
GP says like sure yeah of course I'll do
it but even be better than that is that
something that I wasn't expecting happen
and that's that GP decided to to group
all my notes into nine different
categories and I was like w this is very
cool and I just want to uh share five of
them with you these are copy pasted
directly from gbt chat so anything you
see here can came from GP so let's start
with the first one of them right the
first one is concessions and it says a
significant number of your matches ended
with either you or your opponent
considering which I mentioned before in
some cases you consider due to mistakes
or a poor start that's right while in
others your oppon considered possibly
due to your strong play
wow thank you so so much chat then I
have another one gameplay Reflections
and this one chat is talking about those
notes that I had regarding the game
itself like oh it was intense or this SC
was very close or I had a bad start then
we have another section and this one
mentions specific cards and abilities
for example manafi Greninja draion those
are Pokemon C rest and Mir gate those
are trainer cards then we have another
one and this one is called mistakes and
learning and here I usually write about
those things that I did I know I did
them wrong and that I would like to
avoid in the next game for example I
attack with the wrong Pokemon classic
mistake I set the wrong energies or I
forgot to use certain abilities and
according to chat this no suggest that I
am actively learning from my mistake and
I'm looking for way to improve my game
play and the last category I want to
show is self encouragement so sometimes
uh at the end of the game I have some
notes about how I felt about it so I
have like take it easy and low do not
despair yeah for some reason sometime I
get very anxious playing the game which
I know should be fun right and of course
always remembered uh remember always to
know if you'll be able to retreat kind
of cute right now for the last one a
dashboard in Google Sheets so after I
finished my second project I I was very
happy I thought it was like a very cool
thing to have I learned a lot and yeah
it was fun to do it however I wanted to
do something similar but instead of
collecting data doing a data analysis I
wanted to have like a consistent tool
like a platform where I could see these
values right I wanted some sort of
dashboard let's say and I thought about
building my own website with all this
data and everything and then like no
no use sheets do this same thing you
have here copy paste all the values and
create charts and use the formula so you
can have this information without
actually having to be a whole platform
for doing this and that's what I did so
I started a new Google sheet document
and this one I was okay I'm going to
track data from another deck which I'm
calling lxa something similar and it
contains the same information right so
they have like the same columns that I
have before the very same uh data and I
created another cheat with all these
formulas right so I wanted to to have
the same thing I had before but in a
more readable way well it's not readable
but for me it's understandable and here
the First Column has the win ratio it's
around 80% yes I was quite good playing
this deck at some point and I have the
same thing that I showed before the win
ratio per opponent's deck and we have
some like mu tinl Gengar and Garda which
is either 100% or 50 then we have other
archetypes that I always lost first game
and then once again we have others that
I won the my sample here is only n 19
games at least at the time when I
actually decide to take the screenshot
and then of these 19 games I won 15 and
lost 14 now there's one column that I
wasn't ignoring that's one is the
running win ratio and it wasn't that
easy to calculate this one at least
using those formulas in Google Sheets or
maybe it's actually impossible and I got
quite frustrated I was like I want this
information I have no idea how to do it
so I decided to click around the the
toolbar at uh top of of my cheat and I
saw something called app script and I
was like what is this you know this
sounds like quite useful so I click on
it and I saw a text editor screen and
here I I was able to write some
JavaScript and this is what I did so
apparently you can do things like this
in Google Sheets and I didn't know about
this so I wrote one fun con on edit and
this one is an event that's trigger
every time you edit one sale and I would
like to quickly show it to all of you
right so first I'm going to get my
vactive sheet I'm going to check if I'm
doing if I'm using the right one that's
what I'm checking for the name and the
column and then what I'll do is that I'm
essentially going to get the sale that I
have just added and then I'll also get
all the values that I have from the
first row of that column down to the
edited sale and I'm going to iterate
over all of them I'm going to add them
up all the numbers and then I'm going to
divide them and that's going to give me
the win ratio by that time by that sale
but if I do the same for each sale then
it's going to be some sort of running
win ratio and this is how it looks like
this is the fun part dashboard I have
similar chart as the previous one right
I had the prices remaining at the end of
matches the running win ratio the
opponent's prices remaining at the end
of matches and of course the win ratio
per day which here looks way way better
than the previous one now final words
what am I doing this right yeah like why
am I spending my time to actually play
around with Pokemon data well I like to
find fun ways to apply data to my life I
feel like we usually use data in our
daily uh work in live but I also want to
you know apply it to myself right also
to get better at Pokemon I mean has
become my hobby my obession and of
course I want to improve as much as
possible and to learn New Concept Tech
and tools to be very honest I didn't
know about the hyper geometric
distribution what is that name also
using chat gbd for this it was quite
cool and then also to have a a good
excuse to use Python which I actually
don't use that much at my work since we
are mostly like a Goan U team and did it
help probably not l i mean I think going
it got bit better I think at the game
but I'm not sure if this is actually a
reason why I've been improving so what's
next and maybe some of you could help me
here right
so as fun as this is to do it's very
time consuming right I usually need to
play my game open a new screen going
into Google cheet enter all the data so
I was thinking that may maybe some sort
of software that I could use as side
play maybe like an overlay that I could
for example do one click every time I
get one price that would be cool or even
better has have some kind of very fancy
software that is actually reading my
screen and sorting that information
somewhere so if someone has any idea or
how I could start doing an overlay on
Mac OS please let me know and thank you
so much uh that first link is my GitHub
that's what I have the notebook and my
contact information in case you would
like to keep talking about data tra
safety Pokemon or just say hi so thank
you so much